et bonsoir monsieur redek bonsoir ça va
bien ça va bien mais on se demande si ça
va bien aller justement pour transat
parce que transat votre traverser cette
crise selon vous à tout dépend de
l'intervention du gouvernement dans
plusieurs domaines le domaine de la
quarantaine s'impose au delà aux
voyageurs qui arrivent au canada des
vols internationaux et je pense la
plupart des canadiens ne veulent pas
vraiment passé une quarantaine de ce
qu'ils font un voyage de 12 jours mais
michelin dans l'outre-mer d'abord la
quarantaine fait beaucoup de dommages
sur demande pour le trafic international
et d'autres volets c'est vraiment de
l'intervention du grenat poudre et un
support financier dans le domaine
déviation soit 11 euros par soir
compagnies aériennes d'abord je pense
que ce sont des deux volets qui pourront
et des transats mais si ségolène ne
rentrent en ligne de compte avec lille a
d'abord qui livre qui arrive si lui
aussi en joie que les fortunes de france
assure limité oui et donc est ce que
vous pensez que les gouvernements
doivent venir et principalement le
gouvernement fédéral à la rescousse de
l'industrie de voir c'est une question
si tu fais c'est assez fort mais je
pense qu'il ya vraiment un besoin de
l'apport du gouvernement pour vraiment
aider le secteur
ça fait seulement avec cinq mois six
mois on vraiment que le secteur sauf si
on faisait la pension garde les
compagnies aériennes les coxers
ratissage nombre d'appareils qui sont
rares ou seul de nombreux passagers à
bord des appareils
c'est vraiment une situation qui est
vraiment causé par le fédéral avec le
principe de quarantaine et leurs
principes de gestion de transport
d'admission canada a d'abord je pense
que c'est vraiment une obligation dans
la police fédérale pour nesle à l'aide
de l'aviation est atteint est ce que
finalement c'était une mauvaise décision
pour transat de repartir le 23 juillet
s'imaginant sa lettre la bonne date
est-ce que ça a été une erreur après
coup à tout dépend des situations si
si le gouvernement avait décidé de
désigner d'éliminer la quarantaine du
ton d'être dissout le 15 ou ça aurait
été une décision fait normal de la porte
des transats et des arcades à parce que
les opérations étaient déjà en marche
mais étant donné que ça fait déjà six
semaines que les opérations sont
limitées par une demande qui premarket
20 noms qui n'existe pas à cause de ces
conditions on pose la question si c'est
vraiment une bonne décision d'appel non
seulement des transats mais d'air canada
mène et air canada justement cette
acquisition de transat par air canada
fait déjà plusieurs mois c'était bien
avant la pandémie on était dans un autre
monde
complètement est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui que cette transaction la
pourrait et va échouer les modalités des
transactions sont inchangées je pense
que l'heure de son organe love quelqu'un
l'avait fait est que transat a accepté
qui était de 18,2 hors papa je pense que
si on regarde les transactions de la
transat sur la bourse aujourd'hui en
double et 5 dollars oui d'abord les
valeurs de la france a diminué de
beaucoup sur le marché mais je pense que
les requins d'oeuvre sûrement aller de
l'avant avec la transaction mais un
puits de dh a beaucoup plu beaucoup
moins élevé que le 18/02 lors qu'ils ont
fait des autunois négociation est en
cours vous pensez
si c'est pas encore ça va l'être encore
bien le bientôt mais tous les matches
des gouvernements aussi vous avez la
culture européenne qui fait laquelle
vous avez encore devant le gouvernement
canadien qui peut vraiment dire ou deux
cadres de partis que la transaction ne
va pas aller de l'avant mais mais mais
d'abord même s'ils font de mieux réussir
une négociation de nouveau la
transaction ne sera pas acceptée par les
gouvernements d'abord on atteindre
les décisions des agences gourmand tôt
pour vraiment débuter les négociations
signes associés sans ouverture des
frontières en imaginant que les
frontières restent fermés qu'on garde
les restrictions congard la quarantaine
de 14 jours
la distanciation sociale les masques qui
a pas de financement spécial du
gouvernement combien de temps vous
pensez que transat peut survivre dans
ces circonstances mais si on regarde les
c'est toujours une question de
liquidités monsieur eustache de du
bourget une question de l'équité et puis
si les fonds le seront disponibles sur
le revenu le fait de faire la chance
qu'ils ont environ 250 millions encaisse
maintenant et comme le reportage a
remarqué les capacités de transit
d'aller chercher de l'argent est limitée
par l'entente qu'ils ont avec air canada
d'abord de 250 millions c'est ça qu'ils
ont jamais vraiment aller de l'avant il
devait environ 1.5 et 10 millions par
jour
ah ben moi j'envisage un autre tout au
moins quatre mois peut-être dans trois à
quatre mois
ça sera plus possible de poursuivre
c'est sa franchise ils ont tous deux
fondés l'équité sera zéro et puis sont
pas capables de payer la facture
d'abord parce que moi l'ont pas encore
vraiment une procuration de les
opérations suis bien on va continuer de
suivre de près l'évolution l'avenir de 3
à monsieur bré dec merci pour cette
analyse ce soir désir à la prochaine